this has to be a sham this is what
everybody was talking about please stop
[Music]
hi I'm Ryan
hey I'm Joyce I'm kingsley and I'm
Jasmine and today we are going to blind
taste test
chicken sandwiches and I know one of the
chickens is the famous chicken sandwich
that I have not been able to there's
been some talk about a new chicken
sandwich in town yeah the Popeye
sandwich mm-hmm
which has led all these other chicken
sandwich is to pop up on Twitter
either woodwork claiming their territory
yeah I've recently had the Popeye shinga
sandwich loved it I think I can like
guess that flavor black BAM I know what
that one is I tweeted about it I had a
chicken sandwich from chick-fil-a once
okay and it was cuz it was cater to set
I've never I don't go to these places to
get a chicken sandwich
at all
[Music]
laughs and chicken Popeyes
I already know what it is and I love it
the button is maybe the buttons are what
really give it away but just yeah buns
will get everyone away I'm gonna rock
this bright at the mainland obviously
I'm gonna focus on the chicken right now
let's buy it saying that okay one two
three
Oh whoo oh my god those are naughty
there's something in chick-fil-a
sandwiches oh I don't know if it's like
they're problematic views on the Oh what
like oh yeah I'm not really talking
about damn this chicken Meredith
something there was time and in turn
eight ever put into it she sat know
whatever it is definitely a seasoning
and food map definitely you can actually
taste the chicken uh-huh you found nine
yeah I'm gonna have unit nine mm-hmm oh
god is so good little seven I think oh I
feel like the bread - chicken ratio with
nice I feel like we did taste a pickle
yeah I'm gonna get rid of six and a half
it's pretty good
[Music]
do you feel this this is thick whoo this
one smells really this one has the most
I can smell it the most aroma mm-hmm it
smells like lettuce yeah like that's a
chicken Caesar uh-huh
salad or something it smells like my old
friend oh that's sweet yeah she's a
redhead this one smells really
well-seasoned no I'm not trying to
anything about this trick is that
coleslaw on this every fast-food place
has a smell I smell
what's the mouth what is this what's my
life I don't know like freshly cooked
something cuz they ain't nothing they're
fresh never frozen yeah I think we know
what this is it's coming that that what
you're describing really helped cuz I'm
like yes oh my god this soggy meth yeah
okay I'm not here for this and this was
done by someplace that tried to make
chicken fancy when in reality we just
need it to be good I'm gonna give this a
6 Ivan this one should be six I'm gonna
give this a one because I I couldn't
taste the chicken it's true okay I'm
giving it a two I change mine it's a two
[Music]
Oh in a minute
oh it's firm that bread is firm left
down wait a minute
the mint block the bring on this is like
jam-packed flavor
it's scooping up like roses yeah oh wow
this is I know exactly the places is
this KFC hmm you think you're gonna pop
eyes at all this is not gonna be Popeyes
Chicken
mMmmm I think this is the best chicken
I've tasted does that actually taste
like chicken and you can taste that
mm-hmm
the way the chicken is so seasoned is
really it's well done it's not the shape
of a circle it has a pickle that makes
you want to cry it has the sauce or
mayonnaise it's just like Popeyes was
like I'm tired of playing games with all
these chicken hoes mm-hmm let me show
you the truth mm-hmm
and now I get to finally leave this
can't be papaya there's no way he'll
ever know are you kidding me
stop it this has to be a sham this is
what everybody was talking about and
please stop Popeyes is gonna hinder
I'm gonna give this a five because it
wasn't my favorite and I gave my
favorite a southern this is like a fire
from you I'm gonna give it a sense so
this was gonna win it's gonna be nine
point five because it has the
modifications the access to
modifications that the chick-fil-a
sandwich doesn't have to give this a
nine point five
[Music]
you